so ja heute ist ein bisschen der Wurm in
der Technik drin aber nicht schlimm weil
dann bekommen sie es häufiger mit
wie immer das begriffsnetz
hier ist mir ganz wichtig innere äußere
handlungs unterscheiden und
sprachhandlung ich habe jetzt heute
schon was gesagt das würde nicht
aufgezeichnet deswegen sage ich nicht
noch mal ganz wichtig ihm die Kontexte
viele Wunsch das sind alles jetzt Fragen
die diese Begriffe betreffen die die den
Typ A betreffen von den von den
Klausurfragen also alles das hier ist
eigentlich
ich möchte jetzt einfach mal ein
bisschen weiter springen das haben sie
alle schon gesehen die ganze
freiheitsdebatte ich gebe auch heute
noch mal einen kurzen Rückblick darauf
und ich will noch mal sagen
die schwierigsten Dinge haben wir jetzt
behandelt das sind die schwierigsten
Dinge jetzt haben sie die Grundlagen
hoffentlich verstanden die kann man
durch immer wieder diskutieren und jetzt
wird sozusagen die Kühe jetzt können Sie
diese ganzen Unterscheidung anwenden auf
konkretere Themen und zwar Emotionen zum
Beispiel und da haben wir jetzt als
paradepfähle haben als letzte Mal die
Liebe behandelt natürlich muss ich dazu
sagen haben wir auch hier diskutiert
liebe ist nicht gleich Liebe wenn ich
sage Liebe in einem Kontext und dann
sagen Sie liebe im anderen Kontext dann
ist das nicht dasselbe es geht hier um
eine spezielle Form von Liebe also das
muss ich ganz ganz ausdrücklich sagen es
ist ein Wort Liebe was natürlich so
aufgeladen ist mit Emotionen dass selten
zwei Menschen genau dasselbe drunter
verstehen wir reden jetzt hier von
diesen ganzen Dingen aus dezidiert
philosophischer Sicht und aus
philosophische Sicht ist liebesbegriff
ziemlich eindeutig definiertes kann man
wirklich sagen
der hat eine riesen Tradition kennt
jemand von ihnen Platons Symposium das
Trinkgelage oder Gastmahl genau kann ich
Ihnen sehr empfehlen lesen Sie das mal
das Gastmahl oder vielleicht besser das
Trinkgelage das ist der Eros da steht
natürlich Erotik drin aber das hat gar
nicht so viel mit dem mit Sexualität zu
tun sondern das ist eher eine
Einstellung zur Welt und zu anderen
Menschen und das ist entscheidend und
man kann zur Welt zu Menschen ganz
verschiedene emotionale Haltung
einnehmen
und die Liebe ist eine dieser Form und
die Liebe sagt Harry Frank fährt die ist
auf den Grund bezogen also liebe ist
eine Quelle der Gründe das heißt diese
Emotionen die spielen für unsere
Handlung eine große Rolle
Liebe ist natürlich nicht die einzige
ausgezeichnete Emotion es gibt nur
wenige Emotionen die so ausgezeichnet
sind für unser Handel nämlich auch
Achtung ist eine ausgezeichnete Emotion
das kann man einfach nachweisen durch
die Geschichte der Philosophie in der
ganzen Geschichte der Philosophie gibt
es nur eine begrenzte Anzahl von
Emotionen
auch darüber kann man natürlich wieder
diskutieren ist jetzt ein Gefühl und
eine Stimmung einer Effekt ich gebe
ihnen nachher noch mal ein paar Gründe
dafür warum es eine Emotion ist hängt
natürlich immer davon ab wie man
Emotionen bestimmt ich wollte nur sagen
es gibt nur eine begrenzte Anzahl von
solchen Phänomenen wie Liebe und Achtung
die in der Geschichte der Philosophie
für unser Handeln ganz wichtig sind und
zwar nicht nur für unser Handeln sondern
gerade auch für unsere Autonomie
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier Liebe und
Achtung ganz in die Nähe der Autonomie
gebracht Harry Frankfurt geht so weit zu
sagen in der Liebe sind wir eigentlich
autonom also das was wir durch Liebe tun
in der Liebe tun das ist eigentlich
unsere Selbstbestimmung im höchsten
Sinne
das heißt man muss sich immer fragen
welche Emotionen hält man jetzt für die
Emotionen die mit unserer Autonomie am
besten vereinbar ist das hängt natürlich
immer davon ab was wir unter uns selbst
verstehen je nachdem was wir glauben was
unser Wesen ausmacht unsere eigentlich
Identität wird auch eine andere
Emotionen Zentrum rücken das kann man
sehr schön zeigen anhand des
Unterschieds von Achtung und Liebe
Achtung da gehen wir heute noch mal
drauf ein das ist von Immanuel Kant
Immanuel Kant sagt Achtung ist ein
Ausdruck des kategorischen Imperativs
und das ist deswegen so weit kann sagt
das was uns eigentlich ausmacht ist
unsere Vernunft und unsere praktische
sogar reine Vernunft wir sind nach Kant
eigentlich ein praktisches vernünftiges
Wesen eigentlich sogar ein moralisches
Wesen deswegen sagt ja auch kein
Autonomie selbstbestimmung ist
moralische Bestimmung weil wir im
tiefsten innen moralische Wesen sind da
würden natürlich viele das gerade
bestreiten und sagen wir sind am Ende
keine moralischen Wesen wir können auch
dann autonomen handeln wenn wir nicht
moralisch Handeln hier war das Beispiel
Harry friendfit deswegen sagte die Liebe
hat nur eine Analogie mit dem
kategorischen Imperativ mit dem wieder
Forderung nach selbstzweckhaftigkeit
aber Liebe ist streng genommen gar
nichts moralisches unbedingt das heißt
sie sehen jetzt je nachdem was wir
glauben was wir im tiefsten Inneren sind
so treten auch besondere Emotionen
Zentrum der Handlungstheorie es gibt
noch andere Emotionen die habe ich jetzt
nicht drauf genommen die werden heute
aber auch näher besprechen das ist das
Mitleid wenn wir zum Beispiel sagen wir
sind im Innersten nicht moralische Wesen
oder nicht vernünftige Wesen sondern wir
sind im Innersten Leidensweg gewesen das
sagt autoschobenhauer dann muss als
Basis Emotionen als Grund Emotion hier
doch das Mitleid betraften
wir gehen ja genau noch mehr mit drauf
ein und jetzt habe ich neuen Begriff
hier noch eingenommen nämlich moralische
Motivation also wenn wir hier die
Emotionen diskutieren müssen wir auch
immer schauen was bringt uns dann durch
die Motivation zu Handlung was kann uns
motivieren also motivieren heißt zu
einer Handlung bewegen wir haben schon
mal darüber gesprochen dass es auch
motivationale Gründe gibt also Gründe
die nicht nur rational sind oder also
gute Grund sind oder Gründe die normativ
sind also die irgendwie zwingend sind
sondern wir haben auch mit Gründen zu
tun wenn man sagt das ist jetzt der
Grund der mich zur Handlung bewegt der
hat so eine Art motivationale Kraft und
man kann jetzt auch Emotionen wie Liebe
und Achtung unter dem Gesichtspunkt der
Motivation betrachten er Emotionen sind
beispielhafte for von motivationalen
Quellen also in Emotionen werden sie
selbst auch feststellen wenn sich mal
befragen
da steckt ein Energie in Emotionen und
diese im Energie die treibt uns zur
Handlung an deswegen hat man auch in der
Vergangenheit häufig von sogenannten
Triebfedern gesprochen also von
moralischen Triebfedern der Triebfeder
ist eine
Triebfeder ist eigentlich ein kleines
Teil einer Uhr als ein mechanisches Teil
diese Feder die dafür sorgt dass die Uhr
immer wieder weiterläuft das ist diese
Energiespeicher sie können Energie in
Federn speichern ja und das ist sagen
das was die Unruh in der Uhr in der
aufziehbaren Uhr am Laufen hält ist die
trieb hätte die Energiequelle und so
sprachen in der Vergangenheit heute wird
immer das nicht mehr tun so sprachen zum
Beispiel Manuel kann von der Achtung das
seine moralische Triebfeder eine
Motivationsquelle und Schopenhauer und
wie immer in der Philosophie hat gesagt
das ist völliger Unsinn die Achtung
hilft gar nichts
Beachtung sagt Schopenhauer sein
bequemes Sitzkissen das uns gar nicht
antreibt zur Handlung das ist viel zu
abstrakt die Achtung sagt Schopenhauer
ein Ruhekissen wir brauchen viel
energetischere Emotionen die uns vor
allem dann auch zum moralischen Handeln
bringen ich habe moralisch deswegen in
Klammern gesetzt weil ich hier der
anderen Vorlesung über Moralphilosophie
nicht zu weit vorausgreifen möchte
deswegen mache ich alle moralischen
Begriffe immer in Klammern ja in der
Regel mache ich alles dann in Klammern
weil ich sie vor dem größeren
Hintergrund diskutieren nämlich der
Handlungstheorie
jetzt möchte ich Ihnen noch sozusagen
als kleines Schmankerl ein paar
Positionen der freiheitsdebatte noch mal
nehmen wir müssen die gar nicht
diskutieren die wichtigsten haben wir
genannt und die sind auch nur relevant
für die Klausur aber ich möchte ihn
jetzt noch mal Überblick geben
eigentlich über alle möglichen
Positionen der freiheitsdebatte die
Folien finden Sie übrigens auf Ilias die
aktuell ja und diese Position finden Sie
auch alle falls es interessiert nur die
die auf dem Begriff setzt sind sind für
unsere Klausur relevant aber diese
Punkte finden Sie zum Beispiel auf der
filocast App verlinkt das habe ich
gemeinsam mit einem Kollegen Dr Markus
Marco Hausmann gemacht im Seminar
Determinismus und Freiheit vor 4 Jahren
Universität München da hat man Seminar
zu diesem Thema der terminismus und
Freiheit wer sich mehr von ihnen dafür
interessiert findet die Playlist aller
Videos zu diesem Seminar unter diesem
shortlink oder unter diesem
QR Code können sich anschauen auf
Youtube und jetzt gebe ich da mal einen
Rückblick es gibt naturgesetzlichen
prädeterminismus der Grundgedanke heißt
alle Ereignisse im Universum folgen nur
monologisch nomologisch heißt nach
Gesetzen geordnet ja also gesetzlich aus
längst vergangenen Ereignissen und aus
der Naturgesetzen also zum Beispiel die
Urknalltheorie des Visual
naturgesetzliche redeterminismus dass
man sagt wir hängen letztendlich vom
Urknall ab kausaler Determinismus alle
Ereignisse haben eine Ursachen ja nur
dass sie mal die Begriffe gehört haben
Prinzip der kausalen Geschlossenheit des
physischen alle Ursachen eines
physikalischen Ereignisses sind selbst
physikalisch es kann da nichts anderes
herauskommen wenn alles geschlossen ist
neuronaler Determinismus alle Handlung
des Menschen sind durch unbewusste
neuronale Prozesse verursacht Wolf
singer war unser Fall den wir diskutiert
haben ja all die Position hat vor allem
Herr Hausmann und hier geliefert der
dann absolute Experte ist Skeptizismus
jetzt auch bezüglich auf Freiheit
Skeptizismus gibt es mit Blick auf alles
gibt auch Skeptizismus mit Blick auf
Moral das ist keine Moral gibt so aber
nicht unser Thema es gibt
skeptizismusbezüglich der Freiheit das
heißt wir haben keinen Willen oder wir
können den freien Willen nicht beweisen
es geht gar nicht wir können Freiheit
nicht beweisen ne wir haben den
netzesitarismus alles was geschieht
geschieht aus Notwendigkeit
ist die Notwendigkeit den Agnostizismus
den gibt es natürlich auch in
theologischer Hinsicht aber den nennt
man jetzt hier auf die freiheitsdebatte
an wir können nicht wissen ob wir einen
freien Willen haben sondern ein bisschen
was scharf bisschen was schwächeres als
desktätismus ja
wir können sich richtig wissen
eigentlich könnte man auch so
Skeptizismus verstehen ja aber
Agnostizismus heißt einfach das könnte
sein könnte auch nicht und es gibt
dicker ist einfach noch kritischer
müsste Realismus wir haben ein freien
Willen obwohl die Existenz eines freien
Willens scheinbar sowohl mit der
Wahrheit als auch mit der Falschheit des
Determinismus unvereinbar ist ja also
wir haben in freien Willen aber wir
können den freien Willen nicht erklären
weder mit dem Determinismus noch mit der
Falschheit des terminismus also mit dem
Indeterminismus das heißt mit dem
Kompass mit dem
letztendlich mit dem libertarianismus
wenn man von der Falschheit des
Determinismus ausgeht und das heißt free
will Rema in Mystery das war Peter fun
Invest ich habe ihm das Zitat gebracht
auch das ist eine Position die man
einnehmen kann Fatalismus wir sind nicht
frei und deswegen sind unsere Handlungen
ohne Bedeutung wir sind Spielball uns
bestimmen der Kräfte über die wir nicht
verfügen das ist der Fatalismus der
könnte sich aus dem neuronal der
terminismus ergeben der könnte sich aus
dem Skeptizismus ergeben aus dem
netztarismus also da folgen dann ganz
interessante Dinge diesen Begriffe haben
sie jetzt schon gelernt zu genüge
kompatibilismus Freiheit und der
terminismus sind miteinander sondern der
vereinbar daraus folgt der
inkompatibilismus und der
impossibilismus ist falsch Harry Frank
fährt vertritt einen solchen
kompatibilismus aber da müssen wir nicht
näher drauf eingehen dann noch ein ganz
wichtiger Begriff für uns
inkompatibilismus Freiheit und der
terminismus sind miteinander unvereinbar
daraus folgt der kompatibilismus ist
falsch den libertarianismus haben wir
behandelt Freiheit existiert also die
freiheitsposition ist wahr
Willensfreiheit existiert muss man
genauer sagen und der inkompatibilismus
ist wahr daraus folgt der Skeptizismus
und der Determinismus ist falsch also so
kann man das alles noch meine neue
Ordnung bringen der weiche Determinismus
wir hatten ein bisschen nur den harten
der weiche Determinismus Freiheit
existiert unter der terminismus ist wahr
das heißt daraus folgt der Skeptizismus
ist falsch und der kompatibilismus ist
war zum Beispiel Lock und Jung das sind
weiche Deterministen ja wir hatten mal
John Lock behandelt und David Tube in
harten Determinismus der terminismus und
inkompatibilismus sind wahr daraus folgt
der Skeptizismus ist falsch sie brauchen
die ganzen folgungen nicht alle zu
lernen nur dass sie mal sehen wie
komplex hier die ganze Situation ist
impossibilismus Freiheit und moralische
Verantwortung sind unmöglich daraus
folgt der Skeptizismus ist wahr
semikompatibilismus das kommt jetzt
alles nicht dran der Klausur keine Sorge
nur das ist mal gehört haben moralische
Verantwortung und der terminismus sind
miteinander vereinbar also das ist ein
Riesenfeld der ganzen freiheitsdebatten
ich bringe ihn das nur dass Sie immer
alle möglichen Positionen gesehen haben
nur die Position die wir hier
ausführlich behandelt haben und die auf
dem Begriff sitzt stehen kommen der
Klausur dran aber es schadet nicht Sie
sich mal ein bisschen noch weiter
auszukennen kann man auch im Tutorium
gerne noch ein bisschen im Detail bei
der verfolgen können Sie gerne weiter
diskutieren weil sie dann noch so ein
paar Spielarten weiter behandelt worden
dann möchte ich jetzt einen Rückblick
geben auf Emotionen inwiefern
unterscheiden sich Emotionen von
Gefühlen das war so eine Frage können
Emotionen rational und Gründe unseres
Handelns sein inwiefern können Emotionen
zum Handel motivieren das soll heute vor
allem im Zentrum stehen was sind
moralische Gefühle oder moralische
Emotionen häufig wird Emotionen Gefühl
das Wort gleichbedeutend verwendet jetzt
habe ich gesagt es gibt in der
Geschichte der Philosophie ganz
verschiedene Auffassungen worin sich
eigentlich unser Wesen zeigt
Mitleid ist ein Riesenthema Mitleid wird
von sehr vielen bevorzugt da habe ich
Ihnen schon
artischopenhauer genannt David jung ist
noch eine andere historische Position
die das Mitleid für das eigentlich die
eigentliche moralische oder auch
sonstige autonome Motivationsquelle
Immanuel Kanz sagt nein nein nein nein
nein das ist die Achtung und zwar die
moralische achtung die Hochachtung dann
gibt's noch andere Gefühle die für
Philosophen sehr wichtig geworden sind
nämlich Scham ja man spricht aber jetzt
häufig von Scham Gefühl und nicht von
Charme Emotionen ja das müssen wir gar
nicht weiter diskutieren
Scham ist ein sehr sehr komplexes
Phänomen wer sich interessiert ich mache
dann oben rechts im Video eine Link im
Link rein zum Seminar über
philosophische Themen Emotionen da bin
ich auf die ganzen
Phänomene noch intensiver eingegangen
der Ekel häufig würde man sagen Ekel ist
doch nur so ein Gefühl angenommen Sie
haben da vergammeltes Stück Brot oder
sie kaufen sich irgendwas auf dem
Supermarkt und Sie merken da ist leider
eine Made drin dann würden die
allermeisten von uns sagen eine sehr
widerlegende Gefühl verspüren und dieses
Ekel Gefühl wäre wahrscheinlich sogar
fast schon körperlich ja so mit halbe
übergeben verbunden hat das ist Ekel ist
ein von von vom phänomenalen hier
eigentlich der körperliches Gefühl
natürlich hat die Philosophie diesen
Phänomen dann spezifische Wendung
gegeben wer von ihnen kennt das Buch der
Ekel von Jean Paul sart gelesen ja wenn
es darum den Ekel geht geht's bisher um
ein vergammeltes Brötchen mit einer Made
drin wenn sarte davon spricht das heißt
zartres stilisiert den Ekel für ihn ist
der Ekel ein weltikel der mit der
Absurdität letztendlich auch der
Kontingenz also der ist der Sinn
sinnproblematik der ganzen Welt
zusammenhängt ich will es nur andeuten
wir brauchen auf den Ekel gar nicht mehr
eingehen ich will nur sagen viele dieser
auch körperlichen
Phänomene werden in der Philosophie
stilisiert die Verzweiflung dass es ein
ganz interessantes Phänomen nach so ein
Kill gegangen würde sagen unser Wesen
das was wir sind zeigt sich eigentlich
nicht in der Achtung nicht im Mitleid
sondern in der Verzweiflung sie können
Sie natürlich denken warum war religiös
motiviert und Interessierten seine
Philosophie und die Verzweiflung steht
natürlich immer vor dem Hintergrund
einer möglichen Erlösung ne je nachdem
wie man den Menschen anzieht als
moralisches gewesen oder als Geschöpf
Gottes was in seiner Existenz
verzweifelt ist so ändert sich auch die
Präferenz für die
basisemotion Angst Sören Kirche Gore
wieder und Martin Heidinger auch hier
ist Angst wie bei Sartre ein Phänomen
was stilisiert ist ja wenn man
heutzutage von Angst hört dann denkt man
oder gibt es eine Angststörung oder
psychologische Phänomene sowas meint
jetzt heiliger und Kritiker gar nicht ja
da muss man immer genauer hinschauen was
meinen die darunter wichtig ist hier
noch der Unterschied zur Furcht Angst
und Furcht Furcht ist immer Furcht vor
etwas das kann man immer ganz genau
angeben wofür man sich wovor man sich
fürchtet Angst hingegen und deswegen ist
es auch ein Phänomen was diese beiden
Philosophen interessiert angst ist ein
Phänomen was gar nichts konkretem gilt
sondern der Welt und Existenz als
solcher es ist ein so eine Welt Angst
gewissermaßen und das macht natürlich
Angst zu einem Phänomen was nicht mehr
pathologisch bestimmbar ist ein
philosophische begriff ich wollte ihn
nur hier nur diese Vielzahl an Emotionen
aufzeigen wir konzentrieren uns auf
Mitleid achtung auf Liebe jetzt hier das
sehen sie gibt es ganz prominente
Philosophen und Philosophen Augustinus
hat die Liebe ins Zentrum gestellt
Hannah Arendt hat ihre Dissertation über
die Liebe geschrieben nach Augustinus
und den auch heute behandelten Harry
Frankfurt also liebe wird für viele sehr
zentral
jetzt kann man versuchen hier so ein
bisschen sich zu orientieren das ist gar
nicht so leicht da gebe ich Ihnen auf
jeden Fall das gleich zu das ist nicht
immer so ganz trennscharf aber wir haben
hier gemeinsam schon mal darüber
diskutiert wir haben gesagt Affekte und
da diskutieren wir gleich drüber Affekte
vollziehen sich sehr schnell und
intensiv so dass wir Behandlungen im
Affekt nicht viel reflektieren und
manchmal vor schnell handeln Affekte
sind deswegen keine guten Gründe
Verhandlung darüber möchte mit ihnen
gleich diskutieren sie kennen alle die
Phänomene wie Mord im Affekt also aus
Krimis natürlich oder sonstigen
unbedachten Handlungen im Affekt und
dann würde man sagen was ist denn ein
Effekt zum Beispiel Wut wäre zum
Beispiel einer Effekt oder
Unbeherrschtheit vielleicht auch
Eifersucht oder solche Dinge ja das sind
sehr starke
ja was sehr starke
Phänomene die wir wahrnehmen die uns
übereilt zu einer Handlung motivieren
und motivieren wäre es vielleicht sogar
fast das falsche Wort dafür die uns
nämlich zu einer Handlung treiben schon
fast ne
Stimmungen hingegen die halten an also
Stimmungen sie würden nie hören in
Krimis Mord aus Stimmung aus einer
Stimmung heraus vielleicht ja wir müssen
jetzt immer nicht immer Mord nehmen
sag mal irgendwie Beleidigung aus einer
Stimmung heraus gut vielleicht ja man
ist schlecht gestimmt man ist verstimmt
und dann beleidigt man eine andere
Person
aber es ist irgendwas anderes Stimmungen
die schweben so schlimme Stimmungen
legen sich wie ein Schleier über uns die
färben die Welt wie wir sie wahrnehmen
und sie motivieren nicht so sehr wie es
perfekt tut ich will damit nicht sagen
der Stimmung nicht irgendwie auch
Motivation Wirksamkeit sein könnten aber
die sind eigentlich eher so wie so ein
Schleier irgendwie was leichtes Gefühle
würde ich jetzt davon unterscheiden von
diesen zwei Phänomen weil die eher
äußerlich sind wie schwer zu der Hunger
sie haben einen Schmerzgefühl im linken
Arm eine Biene hat sie gestochen und sie
haben Hungergefühl in sich da würden sie
aber sagen mein innerstes Wesen wird
jetzt nicht durch den Schmerz
ausgedrückt und auch nicht durch den
Hunger der Hunger ist mir äußerlich auch
wenn ich ihn manchmal sehr deutlich
vernehme so dass der Magen knurrt oder
so anders scheint es zu sein mit
Affekten wo sie selbst ganz ergriffen
sind wo sie sagen würden durchaus ja das
war ich das hat mich motiviert auch wenn
ich hinterher auf bereue bei Affekt eben
viel zu impulsiv eine impulsives
Phänomen ist und davon muss man eben
noch die Emotionen
unterscheiden und das ist mir jetzt sind
Angebot Emotionen drücken unsere
Subjektivität aus also wir stehen da
irgendwie ganz dahinter wir sind da ganz
motiviert in Emotionen wie auch im Fall
von Affekten im Gegensatz zum Affekt
erlaubt aber die Emotion dass wir darin
uns noch reflektieren und dass wir da
nicht überwältigt sind wie zum Beispiel
jetzt wenn wir jemanden beleidigen im
Affekt das wäre so mein mein Versuch ist
zu definieren das Phänomen der Emotion
und deswegen weil immer noch eine
Reflexivität mit einbezogen ist weil die
Emotion uns nicht überwältigt wie die
Affekte deswegen eignen sich Emotionen
besonders gut als Gründe und Motive für
unser Handeln und Affekte nicht und
darüber möchte ich jetzt mit ihm kurz
diskutieren ob sie genau dieselben
Intuition haben oder ob man hier noch
was anderes sehen kann
ja wir haben darüber diskutiert gibt es
auch positiv Affekte und ist vielleicht
nicht doch Mitleid ein Effekt weil die
Reflexion darin ja fehlt das finde ich
eine gute Idee und da werden wir jetzt
gleich noch genauer darüber diskutieren
anhand von zentralen Positionen ich
hatte schon Harry Frank Frankfurt
genannt die Frage die uns jetzt
interessiert ist wie hängen Emotionen
mit unserem Handeln zusammen eine Buch
geschrieben ist eigentlich so eine
Aufsatzsammlung nesacity volition love
das sehen Sie Notwendigkeit wird mit dem
Wille letztendlich auch der Freiheit und
der Liebe in eine Verbindung gebracht
das heißt der Begriff nettarismus würde
hier auf Harry Frank wird nicht
zutreffen weil er Notwendigkeit gerade
als ein Ausdruck unsere Freiheit
versteht das sehen sie wieder man kann
die Begriffe so zurechtbiegen dass sie
plötzlich auch mit der Freiheit zusammen
passt ne dann ist ein Buch der Riesens
of Love und die deutsche Übersetzung
lautet Gründe
also hier Liebe ist ein emotionaler
Zustand der mit unserer Vernunft mit
rationalen Gründen kompatibel ist das
ist so sein Grundgedanke das habe ich
schon mal hier vorgelesen ich gebe jetzt
nur die fett gedruckten hervor von mir
love is itself for the Lover source of
Reason also liebe ist für die liebende
Person eine Quelle von Gründen
it createst the reasons bei which his
acts of loving loving concern in
Devotion are inspired also es geht um
Inspiration letztendlich natürlich auch
um Motivation von unserer wie kann ich
mein Handeln begründen wie kann mein
Handel die Energie entwickeln um am Ende
etwas zu tun
und jetzt kommt eine weitere
Charakterisierung der Liebe sagt meine
Liebe wie care about it not also
gegenüber dem Objekt Nord
also wir betrachten das geliebte Wesen
nicht nur als ein Mittel zum Zweck wie
es die instrumentelle Vernunft tut
sondern als ein Selbstzweck ein end das
ist ganz interessant er sagt nämlich
beide jedes the nature loving that we
consider it's object to be valuable in
themes and to be important to us for the
one sakes wenn wir in einer emotional
Einstellung der Liebe zu einer anderen
Person sind dann
instrumentalisieren wir diese Person
nicht sagt Harry Frankfurt sondern wir
betrachten sie als wertvoll an sich
selbst und nicht nur als wertvoll als
Mittel zu einem Zweck das heißt
wir haben darin schon fast zu einem
moralische Einstellung wie sie nach Kant
der kategorische Imperativ gebietet
nämlich andere Person nicht nur als
ermittel zum Zweck zu verwenden sondern
immer auch als
Zweck das ist ganz spannend also dir
liebes sagte hammesstrukturen von
moralische Einstellung enthalten wir
haben aber eben nicht diese strenge
Moral weil es individuell ist Liebe ist
immer individuell hängt mit mir als
Individuum zusammen und die Moral eben
gerade nicht ne und es hat etwas mit
unserer Vernunft zu tun weil uns die
Liebe gute Gründe für unser Handeln gibt
sehr gute Gründe die nicht nur
instrumentelle von uns Gründe sind oder
sind spannende Unterscheidung das heißt
ich fasse mal zusammen nach Frankfurt
ist Liebe eine Quelle vergründung
unseres Handelns damit steht die Liebe
unsere Vernunft nicht entgegen ja weil
sie Gründe sind Gründe haben wir gesehen
haben immer eine rationale Seite Liebe
besitzt eine Ähnlichkeit zu ganz
kategorischen Imperativ da sie fordert
eine andere Person als selbst Zweck zu
behandeln fordern ist vielleicht sogar
schon fast
ungenau ausgedrückt sind in der Liebe
behandeln wie einfach andere Person als
selbstweg da ist gar nicht groß was
gefordert tun wir einfach
ja jetzt kann man sich fragen wo wir
unterscheiden sich jetzt moralische
Gefühle bzw Emotionen von unmoralischen
das habe ich in der Video
Zusammenfassung ihn schon geschickt
gehabt also wir haben hier Mitleid wir
haben achtung wir haben Liebe und ein
Phänomen was mich besonders gerade am
meisten interessiert ist das Phänomen
das Neides darüber würde ich auch mit
ihm gerne ein bisschen diskutieren weil
ich Neid für eine hochinteressante
emotionale Einstellung haltet die häufig
viel zu schnell abgehandelt wird es
gehen aber erst mal aufs Mitleid ein und
hier ist natürlich der vielleicht größte
mitleidsetiger überhaupt oder Mitleids
Theoretiker überhaupt das ist Arthur
Schopenhauer ganz interessanter
Philosoph auch am Wasser seine
Lebensumstände betrifft an hoch
origineller Philosoph von dem viele
sagen er hat als erste wirklich die
moderne Philosophie funktioniert warum
moderne Philosophie weil er über den
europäischen Tellerrand hinausgeblickt
hat ein Verwandter von ihm ich glaube
sein Onkel war Indologe der hat also da
auch plötzlich mal über den Tellerrand
Europas geschaut und gesehen hoppla in
Indien gab es Antike alte Weisheiten die
total spannend sind die ich jetzt in
meine Philosophie mit einbeziehen kann
also für viele ist artischobenarbeit der
erste wirklich moderne globale Philosoph
und deswegen wird Arthur schuppenhauer
natürlich auf in vielen Orten der Welt
sehr gern gelesen weil viele auch damit
ihre Kultur
Verbindung herstellen können exakt
erfolgen ist nichts empört so im
tiefsten Grunde und zum moralisches
Gefühl wie Grausamkeit jedes andere
Verbrechen können wir verzeihen nur
Grausamkeit nicht der Grund hier von ist
das Grausamkeit das gerade Gegenteil des
Mitleids ist also er gewinnt seine
Intuition dafür dass Mitleid die
eigentliche moralische Emotion genug ist
daraus dass es sagt es ist der
Grausamkeit entgegengesetzt und
Grausamkeit ist es unmoralischste also
ist Mitleid des moralischs das ist das
eine Verlängerung ja wenn Grausamkeit
des unmoralischste Phänomens ist was es
gibt wenn Mitleid des Gegenteil von
Grausamkeit ist dann folgt daraus dass
Mitleid des moralische Phänomen von
allen möglichen ist kann man darüber
diskutieren das muss natürlich auch tun
ob man so moralische Motivationen
qualifizieren soll über solche
Extremformen
grenzenloses Mitleid mit allen lebenden
Wesen mit allen lebendem Wesen nicht nur
mit anderen Menschen das ist ganz
interessant mit allen lebenden Wesen ist
der festste und sicherste Bürger für das
sittliche Wohlverhalten und bedarf
keiner Kasuistik mit Kasuistik ist
gemein es bedarf keiner einzelnen
Regelungen wie man jetzt im Detail
Verfahren muss dann ist es einfach
völlig klar wie sich's verhält also ist
die heißt hier gibt's Sonderfälle hier
muss man genau im Detail schauen sagt
Schopenhauer nein wir brauchen gar keine
Detail Regeln Mitleid genügt und ich
weiß wie die Sache läuft ja wer davon
von Mitleid erfüllt ist wird zuverlässig
keine Verletzten keine beeinträchtigen
keinen weh tun viel mehr mit jedem
Nachsicht haben
jedem Verein jedem helfen so viel er mag
und alles seine Handlung wird das
Gepräge der gerecht Möglichkeit und
Menschenliebe tragen jetzt kommt wieder
Liebe ins Spiel
hingegen versuchen man einmal zu sagen
diese Mensch ist tugendhaft aber er
kennt kein Mitleid oder erst ein
ungerechte und boshafter Mensch jedoch
ist er sehr Mitleid mitleidung so wird
der Widerspruch fühlbar und darüber
wollen wir jetzt natürlich gleich
diskutieren das sind starke Thesen die
Schopenhauer jetzt hier anbietet die wir
nicht einfach so natürlich übernehmen
können
wir müssen weiter diskutieren und
deswegen jetzt mal eine Gegenposition
zum Mitleid hören dass die Immanuel Kant
entwickelt hat er sagt
Neigung ist blind und knechtisch sie
vermarkten und gutartig sein oder nicht
und die Vernunft wo es auf Sittlichkeit
ankommt muss nicht bloß den Vormund
derselben vorstellen sondern ohne auf
die Rücksicht zu nehmen als reine
praktische Verlust ihr eigenes
moralisches Interesse ganz alleine
besorgen das ist jetzt nicht so wichtig
was jetzt kommt es ist wichtigste selbst
dies Gefühl des Mitleids und der
weichherzigen teilnehmen wenn es vor der
Überlegung was Pflicht sei vorhergeht
und Bestimmungsgrund wird ist
wohldenkenden Personen selbst lässt sich
bringt ihre überlegte Maximen in
Verwirrung und bewirkt den Wunsch ihre
entledigt und allein der gesetzgebenden
Vernunft unterworfen zu sein
das ist jetzt genau gegen Schopenhauers
Theorie des Mitleids gerichtet und auch
darüber wollen wir jetzt diskutieren ja
wir haben gesehen Mitleid ist verkannt
einfach nur eine Neigung eine blinden
Neigung das heißt die Neigung fehlt es
an Vernunft an objektivitäten Reflexion
es ist zu subjektiv sagt hier auch eine
weichherzige Teilnehmung Weichert sich
sollen nämlich kann nicht sein sondern
soll schön rational begründet sein
müssen Objektive Moral entwickeln und
nicht subjektive die uns zu manchen
Person treibt und so manche Personen
nicht oder auf diese Ebene argumentiert
kann auch gegen die Liebe als moralische
Motivation
ja bei Kanz kannst Theorie der Liebe er
sagt genauso es ist sehr schön aus Liebe
zu Menschen und teilnehmenden Wohlwollen
ihnen Gutes zu tun oder aus Liebe zu
ordnen gerecht zu sein aber das ist noch
nicht die echte moralische Maxime
unseres Verhaltens die unserem
Standpunkte als vernünftige Wesen
als Menschen angemessen ist erkannt
wenn wir uns anmaßen gleichsam als
Volontäre Volontär heißt freiwillig als
Volontäre uns mit stolze Einbildung über
den Gedanken von pflichtweg zu setzen
und als vom Gebote dem Sittengesetz dem
moralischen Gebote unabhängig bloß aus
eigener Lust das tun zu wollen wozu für
uns kein Gebot nötig wäre wir stehen
unter einer Disziplin der Vernunft und
müssen in allen unseren Maximen der
Unterwürfigkeit unter derselben nicht
vergessen ihr nichts entziehen oder dem
Ansehen des Gesetzes ob es gleich unsere
eigene fünf gibt durch
eigenliebigen war das etwas abzukürzen
dass wir den Bestimmungsgrund unseres
Willens wenn gleich dem Gesetz gemäß
doch wohin anders als im Gesetz selbst
und in der Achtung für dieses Gesetz
setzten langes Zitat aber jetzt schauen
Sie sich noch mal die Kritik des
jetzt an auch hier sehen wir ganz viele
Parallelen auch darüber diskutieren wir
kurz
ja nachdem ich jetzt kannst Theorie der
Liebe
besser gesagt seine Kritik der Liebe
auch dargestellt hat gehen wir weiter zu
Friedrich Schiller den möchte ich Ihnen
nämlich auch nicht vorenthalten und
Friedrich Schiller hat jetzt die Liebe
gegenüber kann wiederum verteidigt und
zwar auf eine Weise wie ich gezeigt habe
die derjenigen von Harry Frank wird
ziemlich ähnelt also Harry frank hat
macht eigentlich das was Friedrich
Schiller schon viel früher auch getan
hat der verteidigt nämlich jetzt wieder
die Liebe gegenüber kann sie sehen es
gibt ein Hin und Her darüber kann man
wunderbar natürlich auch Hausarbeiten
dann schreiben Achtung oder Liebe ne
aber das wäre natürlich auch eine
spannende Frage des Typs
geben Sie Argumente für oder gegen die
Liebe als moralische Motivation sowas
wenn eine mögliche Frage da gibt es
nichts vorgeliefertes das müssen sie
dann versuchen mit vielen Gründen zu
erreichen er sagt die Liebe allein ist
eine freie Empfindung denn ihre reine
Quelle strömte vor aus dem Sitz Freiheit
es ist hier nicht das kleine und
niedrige was ich mit dem großen und
hohen Mist nicht der Sinn der an dem
vernunftgesetz schwindelnd hinauf sieht
es ist nicht das absolut große selbst
was in der Anmut und Schönheit sich
nachgeahmt und der Sittlichkeit sich
befriedigt findet nee es ist das absolut
große selbst so daher ist das Gemüt
aufgelöst in der Liebe da es angespannt
ist ist in der Achtung denn hier ist
nicht dass im Schranken setzte da das
absolut große nichts über sich hat und
die Sinnlichkeit von der hier allein die
Einschränkung kommen könnte in der Anmut
und Schönheit mit den Ideen des Geistes
über zusammen stimmt jetzt kommt Liebe
ist ein herabsteigen also von oben nach
unten da die Achtung ein hinaufklemmen
ist daher kann der schlimme nichts
lieben ob er gleich vieles achten muss
daher kann der gute wenig achten was er
nicht zugleich mit Liebe Umfänge der
reine Geist kann nur lieben nicht achten
der Sinn kann nur achten aber nicht
lieben das ist jetzt natürlich wieder
ein ganz anderes Stil sie wissen
Friedrich Schiller sein großer
Dramatiker aber auch ein nicht zu
unterschätzender Philosoph der auch in
dieser Zeit von Kant sehr viel
mitdiskutiert hat auch hier wollen wir
jetzt kurz darüber diskutieren was jetzt
Schiller für so wichtig an der Liebe
ansieht und wie sich das zu Kant verhält
und jetzt bin ich ihn natürlich noch
von Kant etwas schuldig nämlich seine
Theorie der Achtung die habe ich ihn
aber natürlich auch schon präsentiert
er sagt die unmittelbare Bestimmung des
Willens durchs Gesetz und das
Bewusstsein derselben also diese
unmittelbaren Bestimmung des Willens
durch das Sittengesetz und das
Bewusstsein dieser Bestimmung heißt
Achtung so dass diese als Wirkung des
Gesetzes auf Subjekt und nicht als
Ursache desselben angesehen wird und
jetzt kommt eigentlich ist achtung die
Vorstellung von einem Wert der meiner
Selbstliebe Abbruch tut
also ist es etwas was weder als
Gegenstand der Neigung noch der Furcht
betrachtet wird obgleich es mit beiden
zugleich etwas analogisches hat als
etwas Entsprechendes hat der Gegenstand
der Achtung ist also lediglich das
Sittengesetz und zwar da sie nicht dass
sie uns selbst und doch als sich
notwendig auferlegen das Sitten gesetzt
Autonomie als Gesetz sind wir im
unterworfen ohne die Selbstliebe zu
befragen als uns von uns auffällig ist
es doch eine Folge unseres Willens und
hat in der ersten Rücksicht Analogie mit
Furcht
als hier sehen Sie die Spannung des
Sittengesetz ist nach Kant etwas was
ambivalent ist wir haben einerseits
Furcht vor dem Sittengesetz weil es so
unbedingt gilt und andererseits weil wir
erkennen dass es eigentlich unser Gesetz
ist empfinden wir sowas wie Neigung
Gesetz als eine Spannung Analogie von
Furcht und Neigung und das ist eine
Zerrissenheit von der Schiller sagt die
darf in der Moral nicht vorkommen wenn
wir ihn und so zerrissen sind zwischen
Furcht und Neigung vor dem Sitten
gesetzt dann kann das eigentlich nicht
wirklich Moral sein wir brauchen die
Liebe die diese Ungleichheit auflöst und
harmonisch aufhebt das ist Schillers
einzig ja schiller hat also völlig Recht
wenn er sagt bei Kant gibt es eine
Spannung in dem in dem Subjekt im
moralisch handelt
ob er darin recht hat dass diese
Spannung aufgelöst werden muss ist eine
andere Frage
und da kann man groß darüber diskutieren
aber schiller hat jedenfalls recht und
das sagt jetzt eben also kann Achtung
ist die Vorstellung von einem Wert der
meiner Selbstliebe was für ein Wert ist
es nach kann natürlich der absolute
Werte Moral und so konstruiert kann
seine moralische Motivation das ist sagt
wir werden nur dann motiviert wenn wir
durch die Erkenntnis der Moral zugleich
in unseren eigenen Interesse in die in
unsere Individualität
eingeschränkt werden es geht also
zugleich Erhabenheit und Einschränkung
zugleich in der moralischen Motivation
nachkannt und das ist eine Spannung die
Schüler sehr sehr sensibel waren
haben sie dazu noch irgendwelche
Anmerkungen zu achtung wir diskutieren
nämlich gleich drüber noch am Ende was
sie eigentlich für die moralische
Motivation halten überlegen sich das
noch mal im Hinterkopf ob für Sie die
Achtung oder die Liebe oder das Mitleid
eigentlich die geeignete moralische
Motivation ist
jetzt muss ich wieder weiter aufzeichnen
ja wir wollen natürlich auch noch nicht
den den Neid wollen wir auch noch kurz
behandeln kann sagt der neidisch sein
Hang das Wohl anderer mit Schmerz
wahrzunehmen ob zwar dem sein einigen
dadurch kein Abbruch geschieht dem
einigen wohl
Unwille ist der Neid unser Eigenwohl
durch das wohl andere in Schatten
gestellt sie sehen weil wir den Maßstab
des Lebens nicht dessen inneren Wert
sondern nur im Vergleichung mit dem Wohl
anderer schätzen und diese Schätzung zu
versinnlichen wissen also der Neid
besteht darin dass wir durch das wohl
andere selbst in unserem wohl
eingeschränkt werden und das ist
natürlich eine besonders ja
problematische Form des unmoralischen
der Neid nicht so wie der Sadismus dass
wir in unserem wohl erhoben werden wenn
der die andere Person in ihrem Wohl
niedrigt wird sondern im Gegenteil ist
ein umgedrehter seitismus könnte man
sagen ja wir werden unsere
wenn die andere Person in ihrem wohl
wenn sie besser geht und zwar warum weil
kann sagt dass wir hier
den Maßstab nicht in dem inneren Wert
des Wohls Setzens sondern nur in der
Vergleichung mit den wohlantrag wenn wir
uns als immer mit anderen vergleichen
wenn wir unseren Selbstwert nicht aus
uns selbst heraus gewinnen oder
idealerweise aus dem Moral sondern nur
aus dem
Vergleich mit einer anderen Person wie
geht's dir wie viel Geld hat die andere
Person ja welche Note hat die andere
Person ja und so weiter wenn ich nur aus
dieser Relation meint Wert bestimme dann
sagt kann und zwar wie ich finde der zu
treffen dann neiden wir eigentlich
irgendwann die Person und Neid ist nicht
gut weil wir nämlich dann wenn die
andere Person wenn sie besser geht dann
fühlen wir uns automatisch
heruntergesetzt wie eine wie so eine
Wippe nee jetzt kann man natürlich groß
darüber diskutieren gibt es nicht
vielleicht auch positiven Neid der uns
antreibt und wie so ein sportlicher
Ehrgeiz und dann am Ende besser werden
lässt als die andere Person